Bonjour Alain Aspect,
merci de me recevoir,
vous êtes physicien, spécialisé
en optique quantique,
directeur de recherche au CNRS,
professeur à Polytechnique
et à l'institut d'optique
et aujourd'hui on va évidemment parler
de mécanique quantique,
d'intrication, d'inégalité de Bell,
mais puisqu'on a, je sais, pas mal de lycéens,
d'étudiants qui nous regardent
j'avais envie de vous demander de nous
parler de cette période-là pour vous,
quel genre d'élève vous étiez,
qu'est-ce qui vous a donné envie de faire
de la science en général,
de la physique en particulier?
– Alors ce qui m'a donné envie de faire
de la science en général
c'est mes lectures de petit élève
de l'école primaire
qui dévorait les livres de Jules Verne
et puis, arrivé au lycée, à la fin
de mes études de lycée,
en première et en terminale
j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir un professeur de physique
extraordinaire, monsieur Hirsh,
qui a vraiment déterminé ma passion
pour la physique,
c'est quelqu'un qui creusait le programme
un petit peu au-delà
de ce qui était attendu pour passer
le baccalauréat,
qui passait sa vie à monter
des expériences de cours
plus extraordinaires les unes que les autres
et qui surtout, ce qui à mon avis n'est pas
toujours le cas au lycée,
nous a fait comprendre quelle était
la différence
entre les mathématiques et la physique,
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'en physique
il faut toujours prendre le modèle le plus
simple, l'approximation la plus simple
et ça, c'est lui qui a déterminé toute ma
carrière, donc je lui dois vraiment cela.
– On va venir maintenant à ce qui était
le sujet de votre doctorat
donc ces expériences de violation
des inégalités de Bell,
et ses expériences ont permis de trancher
un vieux débat
qu'il y avait entre Bohr et Einstein,
est-ce que pouvez nous rappeler
quels étaient les termes de ce débat
entre ces deux savants?
– Ce débat a duré je dirais depuis
les années 1920
jusqu'à la mort de nos deux grands physiciens
dans les années 50.
Au fond c'est un débat qui porte sur
la représentation que l'on a du monde.
Einstein était un "réaliste", être réaliste
ça veut dire qu'on pense
que le monde existe indépendamment
du fait que nous l'observons
et que ce monde a des propriétés
et que le but de la physique
c'est de découvrir les propriétés
du monde qui existe.
Et Niels Bohr s'est convaincu que
pour arriver à progresser et à résoudre
les difficultés qui se présentaient
à la physique traditionnelle
qui était évidemment réaliste, la physique
du 19e siècle était réaliste,
Bohr s'est convaincu qu'il fallait
renoncer
à imaginer qu'il y avait vraiment
un monde avec toutes ses propriétés
et que la seule chose qui comptait
c'est les propriétés que l'on peut observer.
Et Einstein pensait que cette façon
d'aborder les problèmes
n'était qu'une étape provisoire,
c'est-à-dire, il ne remet pas en cause
la physique quantique
telle qu'elle a été développée
dans les années 1910 -1920,
d'ailleurs il a lui-même énormément
contribué à ce développement
mais il pensait que ce n'était
qu'une étape provisoire
c'est-à-dire que, certes on savait décrire
les observations,
que l'on savait rendre compte
des observations,
mais il pensait qu'une vraie théorique
physique devait aller au-delà
et nous parler du monde tel qu'il est et non
pas seulement de ce que nous observons.
Et donc là où la démarche d'Einstein
est extraordinaire
c'est qu'il ne s'est pas contenté
de faire
des discussions philosophiques
épistémologiques,
il a essayé d'imaginer ce qu'on appelle
des "expériences de pensée"
c'est-à-dire des expériences qu'en principe
on pourrait faire
même si la technologie n'est pas
tout à fait assez avancée,
il a essayé d'imaginer des expériences
de pensée pour montrer
que se borner à la vision dite
"de Copenhague",
celle de Niels Bohr et de ses élèves
où on dit:
"il y a ce qu'on peut observer
et rien d'autre"
il a essayé de trouver des auto-contradictions
dans cette présentation des choses.
– Quand on regarde un peu l'histoire
de ce sujet là,
on a l'impression d'une certaine manière
que Bohr, d'une certaine façon
a réussi a "tué le débat", et que
la génération qui a suivi, de physiciens,
n'a pas vraiment vu l'intérêt,
ou n'a pas voulu se pencher à nouveau
sur cette question,
et l'impression que j'avais c'est que,
même après la publication de John Bell
en 1964,
donc c'était après la mort de Bohr
et d'Einstein, la publication de John Bell,
on a l'impression qu'elle est même passée
relativement inaperçue.
C'était dans un journal
qui venait d'être créé
et lui-même disait qu'il travaillait dessus
en cachette ou le weekend.
Alors comment est-ce que vous,
vous avez découvert les travaux,
le fameux papier de Bell, et qu'est-ce que
vous avez lu dans ce papier
qui vous a donné envie de vous attaquer
à cette aventure?
– Je pense qu'il faut expliciter auprès
de nos auditeurs
ou de nos spectateurs ce relatif désintérêt
vis-à-vis du débat.
Il faut se rendre compte que la physique
quantique est quand même probablement
la théorie la plus fructueuse de toute
l'histoire de la physique.
Bien sûr il y a eu le mouvement des planètes
etc. mais finalement c'est un sujet limité.
La mécanique quantique a répondu
aux questions majeures qui se posaient
à la fin du 19e siècle:
pourquoi la matière est-elle stable?
Qu'est-ce que la liaison chimique?
comment le courant électrique est-il conduit
à l'intérieur des matériaux?
comment la lumière est-elle émise
et absorbée?
Donc la physique quantique telle
qu'elle a été développée
d'une façon à peu près complète à partir
de la fin des années 1920
a eu des succès faramineux,
donc les jeunes physiciens
qui entrent dans le domaine,
apprennent la physique quantique,
l'applique et… succès sur succès.
Et puis on leur explique qu'il y a un débat
entre Bohr et Einstein qui sont déjà vieux,
et donc ils se disent:
"bon on n'a pas de temps à perdre".
En plus, ce qu'il faut bien comprendre,
c'est qu'à l'époque,
c'est pour ça que je voulais revenir
sur ce point-là,
à l'époque le débat est de nature
épistémologique,
c'est-à-dire que Einstein ne remet
en rien en cause
les prévisions de la physique quantique,
tout ce qu'il dit c'est:
"je ne suis pas d'accord avec votre façon
de l'interpréter,
mais les calculs et résultats des équations,
pas de problème je les accepte,
d'ailleurs j'ai moi-même contribué à mettre
en place le formalisme etc.
Donc on peut penser qu'un jeune physicien
actif qui utilise avec succès
la physique quantique tous les jours se dit:
"ouais il doit y avoir un problème
épistémologique là derrière,
quand je serai plus vieux, que je serai
à la retraite,
j'aurai le temps de réfléchir,
il sera toujours temps d'y penser."
Et alors, à ce moment-là, arrive effectivement
le travail de John Bell
qui remet complètement en cause
cette vision des choses,
c'est-à-dire que… et c'est pour ça
que ça va prendre de l'importance,
mais les gens ne se rendent
pas compte au début,
puisque après John Bell, eh bien suivant
qu'on adopte
la position de Bohr ou la position d'Einstein
il y a certaines situations très rares
dans lesquelles on va arriver
à des conclusions différentes,
des conclusions numériques différentes
et après "y a qu'à" faire l'expérience
pour savoir qui a raison entre les deux.
Mais donc il faut voir que avant de comprendre
que John Bell représente cette rupture
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'on va pouvoir
trancher par une expérience
un débat qui jusque là était de nature
philosophique, épistémologique,
eh bien il va falloir que les idées
de John Bell diffusent,
et ça va prendre, on va dire
une bonne dizaine d'années.
– Et c'est à peu près à cette période-là…
– Alors vous m'avez demandé… ah ben moi,
j'ai eu la chance
qu'on me mette entre les mains un dossier
qui avait été amené par Abner Shimony.
Abner Shimony était un physicien américain
qui avait une double culture, philosophe
et physicien théoricien,
et qui s'était beaucoup intéressé au problème,
qui était venu à l'université d'Orsay
invité par Bernard d'Espagnat,
il avait fait des séminaires et celui
qui est devenu mon directeur de thèse,
Christian Imbert, avait récupéré un dossier,
à l'époque il n'y avait pas internet,
il y avait un dossier dans lequel
le premier article était cet article de John Bell,
dont on a parlé, qui était un article
introuvable
parce qu'il était dans une revue pratiquement
très peu diffusée,
et donc j'ai eu la chance de tomber
sur ce papier de Bell,
je me rappelle très bien,
le premier jour où j'ai lu cet article
j'ai dit: mais c'est sur ça
que je veux travailler!
Ça me semblait le problème le plus
extraordinaire dont on n'avait jamais parlé,
dont je n'avais jamais entendu parler,
faire une expérience qui permettrait
de trancher un débat entre Bohr et Einstein.
– Pas mal!
– Pas mal hein?
Alors on va parler maintenant
de cette série d'expériences
que vous avez réalisées à la fin
des années 70 et au début des années 80.
Le premier point c'est qu'en fait, d'abord
si ces expériences ont été possibles
c'est notamment grâce au travail
que vous avez d'abord fait
sur la source des photons intriqués,
c'est déjà un travail qui vous a pris
plusieurs années
et moi d'ailleurs, c'est une question
que j'ai régulièrement
quand je parle d'intrication, on me dit:
"mais comment on fait pour fabriquer
des particules intriquées? "
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
le principe de cette source?
Et ce qu'elle apportait de nouveau
et qui rendait possible cette expérience?
Alors d'abord il faut préciser,
parce qu'en science il faut toujours
citer ses sources,
il faut préciser que l'idée fondamentale
de cette source,
elle remonte aux années 70,
aux premières expériences,
celles qui ont été faites par John Clauser
et Stuart Freedman, à Berkeley.
Et l'idée c'est d'utiliser un atome,
un atome tout seul,
Alors il y en a beaucoup, mais beaucoup
de fois un atome tout seul
qui, par la façon dont il va émettre
2 photons en cascade (je vais y revenir)
le processus-même d'émission est tel
que ces 2 photons vont être intriqués
en polarisation
donc il faut qu'on parle d'intrication,
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire intriqués
en polarisation?
Donc dans la vidéo, les spectateurs vont voir
que la polarisation
c'est en quelque sorte la direction
dans laquelle vibre le champ électrique
par rapport à la direction de propagation
et que finalement cette polarisation
c'est un vecteur
qui est dans un plan et donc, comme
tout vecteur qui se trouve dans un plan
finalement on est dans un espace
de dimension 2
et donc il faut deux états de base
pour décrire.
Donc, par exemple vertical/horizontal
ou bien en diagonale droite/diagonale gauche,
on pourrait aussi dire
circulaire droit/circulaire gauche.
Ensuite parlons de l'atome,
on a donc un atome,
on le porte dans son état excité
et on a un schéma dans lequel
l'atome va se désexciter et il ne peut pas
passer directement
à l'état fondamental en émettant
un seule photon,
il est obligé de passer
par un état intermédiaire
donc il va émettre un premier photon,
et un deuxième photon,
c'est ce qu'on appelle
une "cascade radiative".
Et ces deux photons vont être émis
avec un intervalle de temps très bref
entre les deux, de l'ordre
de quelques nanosecondes.
Maintenant cet état intermédiaire, il est
ce qu'on appelle "dégénéré"
c'est-à-dire en fait ce n'est pas
un état unique,
mais il y a plusieurs possibilités
sur cet état intermédiaire,
et on va en sélectionner deux,
de ces possibilités.
Si la désexcitation se passe en passant
par le premier chemin
nous allons dire que nous émettons
deux photons polarisés verticalement,
mais si la désexcitation se passe
par l'autre chemin
nous allons dire que la désexcitation se fait
horizontalement.
Et maintenant on va toucher au fond
du formalisme quantique,
si 2 chemins sont possibles et s'il n'existe
aucun moyen, à la fin,
de distinguer entre ces deux chemins
alors on doit en prendre en compte
les deux à la fois.
Et donc quand mon atome, partant de l'état
du haut, sera arrivé dans l'état du bas,
eh bien la paire des deux photons
sera À LA FOIS
vertical/vertical ET horizontal/horizontal.
J'insiste sur ce "à la fois" "et",
c'est aussi extraordinaire
que le chat de Schrödinger
qui est À LA FOIS mort ET vivant.
Attention, ce n'est pas: ça + ça = 45*
Non c'est toujours ça et ça en même temps
donc c'est ça l'intrication
et donc là c'est la nature elle-même,
la façon dont la lumière est émise
par cet atome
qui va me donner une paire
de photons intriqués.
Alors après quelle est la difficulté
de l'expérimentateur?
C'est que: une seule paire de photons
on ne peut pas en faire grand chose.
Il faut en avoir beaucoup, or a priori,
si on prend beaucoup d'atomes
qui émettent en même temps,
on a une espèce de salade
et on a une lumière qui est
un peu aléatoire.
La "magie" du physicien ou la chose
extraordinaire dans ce système,
j'ai insisté sur le fait que entre le premier
et le deuxième photon
ne s'écoule qu'un temps
de quelques nanosecondes.
Donc si maintenant j'ai beaucoup d'atomes
qui émettent en même temps,
mais quand même qu'il n'y a pas
un rythme phénoménal,
disons un million par seconde,
un million par seconde ça veut dire
qu'en moyenne s'écoule
mille nanosecondes entre deux émissions
par deux atomes,
donc je peux parfaitement identifier
les deux photons issus du même atome,
puisque c'est séparé seulement
par quelques nanosecondes.
En regardant des détections qui ne sont
séparées que de quelque nanosecondes
je regarde individuellement les émissions
alors qu'en réalité
j'en ai beaucoup qui sont en train d'émettre
en même temps.
Et donc finalement, je suis au cœur de ce
que j'aime bien appeler
"la deuxième révolution quantique"
où j'ai deux ingrédients,
d'une part la mise en œuvre de l'intrication,
mais aussi le fait que je suis capable
d'identifier
des phénomènes quantiques individuels,
ici je regarde les paires une par une,
si je regarde le grand paquet, je ne suis
plus dans la seconde révolution quantique
et je ne verrai pas la violation
des inégalités de Bell.
Donc j'ai mis en œuvre les deux ingrédients
de la seconde révolution quantique
par ce schéma expérimentale
– Et la source que vous avez utilisée
elle était bien plus efficace que…
par exemple les premières tentatives avaient
été faites donc par Clauser/Freedman
et ils avaient une source qui permettait
de façon beaucoup plus difficile
d'avoir la statistique nécessaire,
quelle était la spécificité de celle
que vous avez utilisé?
– J'ai bénéficié des progrès formidable
des lasers
et en particulier d'une méthode qui avait
été développée au début des années 70
notamment par une équipe parisienne,
celle de Bernard Cagnac,
Gilbert Grymbert, François Biraben,
Élisabeth Giacobino,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'excitation
à deux photons.
Je reprends mon atome avec
le niveau du bas et le niveau du haut,
j'ai expliqué qu'il ne peux pas émettre
directement vers le bas,
eh bien par réciprocité, on ne peut pas
l'exciter directement
en lui faisant absorber de la lumière.
Et donc Clauser et Freedman avaient recours
à un stratagème
qui consistait à exciter un niveau beaucoup
plus élevé avec un photon ultraviolet,
mais en fait une lampe ultraviolet,
et à partir de là, ça se débrouillait,
alors la plupart des atomes tombaient
par où ils pouvaient
et de temps en temps, par chance,
il y en a un qui passait par la bonne trajectoire.
Grâce à la méthode de l'absorption
à deux photons,
en empilant deux photons laser
qui permettaient maintenant de connecter
directement l'état fondamental
à l'état excité
parce qu'avec un seul ce n'est pas possible
mais avec deux c'est possible
on arrivait à viser exactement
le niveau du haut
et on arrivait à exciter spécifiquement
qui était intéressant pour l'expérience,
et une fois l'atome excité
dans le niveau du haut,
la seule chose qu'il pouvait faire,
c'était émettre la paire dont on avait besoin.
Donc source à la fois très pure,
il n'y avait pas tout le bruit ambiant,
si j'ose dire,
créé par les autres systèmes, donc source
très pure et puis surtout
on pouvait régler le taux d'émission,
et d'ailleurs on ne cherchait pas à l'obtenir
le plus grand possible car,
si on se souvient de l'explication
que j'ai donné il y a une minute,
si la cadence était trop élevée on finirait
par mélanger les photons qui ne sont pas
émis par le même atome.
Donc on pouvait se mettre à l'optimum,
c'est-à-dire une cadence telle
que les paires individuelles
restaient bien séparées
Donc, ça c'était évidemment formidable,
ça a demandé beaucoup de travail,
disons que j'ai démarré cette expérience
en 1975
et que la source a fonctionné
cinq ans plus tard.
C'était l'époque bénie où les thèses
d'État pouvaient durer… des années!
– Alors si on vient maintenant à la deuxième
pièce essentielle
dans le dispositif, ce sont les polariseurs
et l'idée c'est de pouvoir mesurer
la polarisation des photons
selon une direction qu'on a envie
de faire varier,
et donc ce qu'il y a de vraiment particulier
dans cette expérience,
c'est que la violation des inégalités
de Bell,
dans ces situations finalement assez rares
où Einstein et Bohr disaient
des choses différentes,
elle n'est pas du tout obtenue pour
tous les réglages de l'expérience,
il y a vraiment des orientations particulières
qu'il faut essayer de viser.
– Oui, alors il y a deux choses.
Il y a d'une part les orientations
particulières qu'il faut viser
et je pense que nous y reviendrons
dans un moment,
il y a aussi le fait d'être capable
de changer au dernier moment.
Alors parlons déjà des orientations
particulières,
je pense que dans la vidéo les spectateurs
auront compris
que finalement lorsqu'on a deux mesures
à distance qui sont corrélées,
c'est-à-dire que la mesure d'un côté est
proche de celle qui est de l'autre côté etc.
Une image naturelle consiste à dire:
quand les deux particules sont parties
elles avaient une propriété commune,
et c'est cette propriété commune
qui détermine la corrélation.
Il faut savoir que cette image marche
PRESQUE tout le temps,
et c'est un résultat extraordinaire
de la mécanique quantique
découvert par John Bell, que même Einstein
n'avait pas découvert,
découvert par John Bell, que parfois,
sur certains types d'orientation,
eh bien cette image que je viens de décrire
pour les photons en disant:
les deux photons dès le départ ils ont
une polarisation donc je comprends bien,
ils se sont mis d'accord etc.,
cette image ne va pas fonctionner.
Et ça on s'aperçoit qu'il n'y a…
et pour ça il faut les mathématiques
des inégalités de Bell,
on s'aperçoit qu'il n'y a que certaines
orientations précises
qui vont donner lieu à un conflit
entre ce qui est prévu
dans la vision d'Einstein et
ce qui est prédit dans la vision de Bohr.
Donc il faut avoir des polariseurs
qui puissent être réglés en orientation
et par ailleurs,
il faut des polariseurs d'excellente qualité
pour que le résultat soit suffisamment net,
parce que la différence entre les deux
prévisions n'est pas si grande que ça.
– Alors, au moment où vous commencez
ces expériences
on peut dire que, a priori les deux résultats
étaient possibles.
On pouvait imaginer tomber sur effectivement
une violation des inégalités de Bell
ou bien a contrario montrer que finalement
la vision de Einstein était la bonne.
Et est-ce que vous vous êtes rendu compte
à un moment précis que,
"ça y est" ça penchait dans une direction,
est-ce qu'il y a eu un moment où vous dite:
"oui ça y est les inégalités de Bell
sont violées"?
– Alors il faut répondre en deux étapes
à cette question.
Quand je commence en 1974
on est encore avec deux résultats,
celui de Clauser/Freedman à Berkeley,
et celui de Holt et Pipkin à Harvard,
et Clauser/Freedman trouvent une violation
des inégalités de Bell,
mais Holt et Pipkin à Harvard ne trouvent
pas une violation des inégalités de Bell,
mais dans les deux cas,
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure,
finalement le signal est très faible,
il faut accumuler pendant longtemps,
bon on a bien l'impression que l'expérience
de Clauser/Freedman est un peu mieux maîtrisée,
surtout on peut mieux changer les paramètres
que dans celle d'Harvard,
mais la question est ouverte.
En 1976 Ed Fry au Texas, fait une expérience,
c'est la première expérience dans laquelle
il excite avec un laser,
il n'a qu'un laser, il excite avec un laser
sa source
et déjà il améliore le rapport
signal sur bruit,
et donc ça commence à pencher en faveur
de la mécanique quantique,
mais disons on est quand même dans le domaine
des expériences que l'on peut discuter.
et donc pendant ce temps, je mets au point
ma source qui est infiniment meilleure
que toutes les sources précédentes etc…
Et puis il va y avoir la première expérience,
et là je suis obligé de rentrer
un tout petit peu dans les détails:
toutes les expériences précédentes
avaient été faites avec des polariseurs,
qui contrairement à l'image théorique,
ne donnent pas le résultat "plus et moins",
je ne sais pas comment on les appelle
dans la vidéo,
ils donnent un seul résultat, et l'autre
résultat, simplement: pas de détection.
Et donc on est obligé de faire une petite
gymnastique intellectuelle
qui a l'air très simple, mais qui
en pratique est compliquée,
qui consiste à dire: si je détecte,
c'est le résultat comme ça,
et si je détecte pas c'est l'autre.
Oui mais ne pas détecter ça peut être aussi
tout simplement avoir perdu le photon,
donc ça oblige à faire des inégalités
un petit peu indirectes etc.
Et donc une fois que ma source est au point,
je commence par faire une expérience
de même nature que celles des prédécesseurs,
et simplement j'ai un meilleur rapport
signal sur bruit,
donc c'est clairement une violation
des inégalités de Bell,
mais encore violation des inégalités de Bell
un petit peu trafiquée, modifiée,
pour tenir compte du fait qu'on rate
l'un des deux résultats,
et puis entre-temps, avec un étudiant
qui vient me rejoindre,
et qui fait sa thèse de 3e cycle avec moi,
qui est venu me rejoindre à ce moment-là,
il s'appelle Philippe Grangier, il est devenu
une star mondiale de l'optique quantique,
et donc avec lui pour sa thèse de 3e cycle,
on a développé pour la première fois
des polariseurs
où on pouvait obtenir les deux résultats,
et donc à ce moment-là,
on met 4 détecteurs: plus-plus, plus-moins,
moins-plus, moins-moins,
et on va faire une expérience dont
instantanément
la statistique va être phénoménale.
– Oui, vous aviez une significativité
en nombre de sigma qui était…
– Alors non seulement en nombre de sigma,
la violation des inégalités de Bell
par 40 ou 50 sigmas,
mais le plus impressionnant,
c'est que, pour chaque valeur des angles
entre les polariseurs,
le point tombait sur la courbe prévue
par la mécanique quantique
à plus ou moins 1 ou 2 sigmas,
ce qui est exactement
ce qui est prévu par la statistique,
et ça c'est absolument phénoménal,
et disons qu'à ce moment-là,
je suis très sérieusement ébranlé,
c'est à dire, je me dis:
"Il y a pas de doute la mécanique quantique
a l'air de très très bien marcher",
mais il reste quand même l'autre point,
l'autre point qui est en fait la raison
pour laquelle je me suis embarqué
dans cette histoire,
c'est que quand on lit bien Einstein,
et qu'on lit bien Bell,
le fameux papier de 1964,
les hypothèses nécessaires à l'obtention
des inégalités de Bell,
dans ces hypothèses,
il faut dire que la détection d'un côté,
et la détection de l'autre côté
sont indépendantes,
ne peuvent pas conspirer entre elles.
"Conspirer" c'est une façon de dire
qu'il y a une interaction,
et comme Bell l'avais suggéré
dès son papier de 1964,
moi, mon objectif, c'était d'empêcher
toute possibilité de conspiration,
en choisissant au dernier moment
l'orientation du polariseur
qui est de ce côté-ci, de telle sorte
que l'autre qui est là,
ne "sait pas", au moment de la mesure,
quelle est l'orientation de celui-ci,
et on bloque ainsi toute
possibilité de conspiration,
et là où c'est merveilleux,
c'est pour ça que, dès le début,
c'est ça que j'ai voulu faire,
c'est d'ailleurs ce que j'ai proposé dès 1975,
et bien c'était d'utiliser encore une fois
Einstein et la relativité d'Einstein,
pour bloquer toute possibilité
de communication puisque,
d'après la relativité d'Einstein,
rien ne peut aller plus vite que la lumière,
il me suffisait donc d'avoir un intervalle
de temps
suffisamment court entre les choix
des orientations des 2 côtés,
pour qu'aucune conspiration ne soit possible,
il restait donc cette 3ème expérience à faire,
et là sur cette 3ème expérience,
je me rappelle très bien le jour
où on a fait la première expérience,
Philippe Grangier, qui entre-temps
était allé faire un stage ailleurs,
donc il ne participait pas directement
mais il était venu,
il y avait Jean Dalibard, qui lui,
était venu nous rejoindre pour
la dernière année aussi,
c'était un jeune étudiant
qui lui aussi a fait son chemin.
– Une belle carrière.
– Une belle carrière, était venu nous rejoindre,
et on était là, et on regardait en temps réel
la statistique se construire,
et bien il n'y avait aucun doute,
même en basculant très vite les polariseurs,
on continuait à violer les inégalités de Bell,
je me rappelle très bien Philippe Grangier,
annoncer à haute voix, il dit:
"on les a violées par un sigma,
on les a violées par deux sigmas", voilà.
– En fait, ce qui est extraordinaire
dans cette expérience,
c'est que non seulement les polariseurs
doivent être suffisamment éloignés,
donc d'une dizaine de mètres c'est ça?
– Oui, 12 mètres.
– Et vraiment enfin c'est difficile
à concevoir
c'est que l'orientation du polariseur
ait varié pendant le temps de vol du photon
de la source jusqu'au…
– Oui, on peut parler des ordres de grandeur.
– Oui, c'est ça.
– A 12 mètres, il faut 40 nanosecondes
pour qu'un signal se déplaçant
à la vitesse de la lumière,
aille d'un bout à l'autre, et de chaque côté,
je variais toutes les 10 nanosecondes,
donc 10 nanosecondes, c'est incontestablement
moins que les 40, même que la moitié,
on peut discuter si il faut la moitié ou pas
voilà.
– Alors, vous l'avez évoqué,
c'est quelque chose qui m'a surpris en fait
en préparant cette interview,
j'ai été relire vos publications
et donc notamment,
vous citez une de vos publications
antérieures que vous avez faite en 1976,
dans laquelle vous annonciez votre intention
de faire ce dispositif là,
donc vous annonciez l'idée en quelque sorte
et ça m'a surpris en fait,
de découvrir que tout ça était prévu depuis
le départ en quelques sortes,
est-ce que c'est pas un peu risqué à l'époque
de, comme ça, de dévoiler ses plans?
Enfin vous aviez cette idée qui permettait de…
– Et bien, ça me donne l'occasion de tirer
un grand coup de chapeau à John Bell.
En réalité la première publication,
elle est même en 1975,
c'est à dire il y a une publication courte
en 75 et celle de 76 que vous citez,
c'est une élaboration avec une démonstration
de mathématiques,
mais l'idée de base est en 1975,
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?
Lorsque ce jeune professeur de l'institut
d'optique, Christian Imbert,
m'a tendu le dossier dans lequel j'ai trouvé
le papier de Bell en me disant:
"Écoute, regarde, y a peut-être quelque chose
qui va t'intéresser là-dedans",
je suis revenu le voir,
je lui ai expliqué mon idée
et mon idée dès le départ était de dire:
"Je vais changer les orientations
des polariseurs
parce que ça c'est l'essence du conflit
entre Einstein et Bohr,
tant que je ne change pas les orientations,
oui d'accord c'est intéressant,
mais en changeant c'est mieux.
Il faisait partie d'une génération
qui finalement
n'avait pas énormément étudié
la physique quantique,
il m'a dit: "Ça m'a l'air très intéressant,
mais je ne suis pas sûr de comprendre
en détail,
donc tu vas à Genève,
tu discutes avec John Bell
et si John Bell trouve que c'est une
expérience intéressante,
alors tu auras des mètres carrés
dans mon laboratoire pour la faire",
donc je suis allé voir John Bell,
donc on parle là du printemps 1975,
l'idée je l'ai développée on va dire,
entre novembre et décembre 1974,
donc on est au printemps,
peut-être en février 75,
je vais voir John Bell,
je lui raconte mon idée,
et donc après une petite anecdote
que je raconte N fois,
la première question qu'il m'a posée:
il m'a demandé si j'avais un poste
permanent ou pas.
Alors que je demandais pourquoi,
il m'a expliqué que je serai considéré comme
un "crackpot" comme on dit en anglais
c'est-à-dire un type
qui fait des choses sans intérêt etc.,
et que si je n'avais pas de poste permanent,
il me décourageait, je dis que si si,
le système français était tel que j'avais
déjà un poste d'assistant,
bon il m'a dit: "Très bien",
donc là on a parlé, il était enthousiaste,
Bell il m'a chaudement encouragé,
il m'a dit dans ce cas-là il faut y aller,
il faut faire,
et je lui ai posé exactement la question,
je lui ai dit: "Maintenant j'ai cette idée",
quand même j'avais une idée un peu originale
sur la façon de tourner les polariseurs
et je lui dis: "Est-ce que j'ai intérêt à garder
cette idée pour moi ou bien la publier? "
et là John Bell, avec un air de prêcheur,
il ressemblait un petit peu à un prêcheur
irlandais, il m'a dit:
"Mais jeune homme, nous parlons ici
de recherche fondamentale,
en recherche fondamentale tout est ouvert,
vous m'avez raconté votre idée,
moi je vais la raconter, je vais dire:
"Il y a un jeune français
qui fait cette expérience",
donc la seule chose que je peux vous dire
c'est: "vous publiez",
et donc immédiatement, j'ai publié dans
un petit article en 75, la première idée,
et je dois dire que je pense que c'était
un conseil absolument excellent,
d'abord pour les raisons de fond
qu'il m'a dites,
et même pour des raisons d'opportunisme,
parce que combien de fois
dans la période plus récente
où j'ai eu la chance de recevoir
un certain nombre de prix,
et bien le jury du prix m'a posé la question:
"Mais qui a eu l'idée de l'expérience? "
et j'ai répondu: "Mais c'est moi".
"Mais vous pouvez le prouver? "
"oui, j'ai la publication 75
dont je suis le seul auteur".
Donc, non seulement il avait raison
sur le plan moral
et en plus, c'était un excellent conseil.
– Et alors du coup,
je rebondis là-dessus parce que,
une chose qui est assez étonnante quand on
regarde l'évolution de ce sujet-là,
on a presque l'impression que c'est
finalement grâce à vos expériences
que les gens ont vraiment découvert
et compris ce qu'avait raconté Bell,
et que ce sujet qui était considéré comme
soit sans intérêt,
soit à la limite sulfureux,
est devenu un sujet presque respectable
peut-être parce que devenu expérimental.
– Alors, il y a plusieurs éléments
de réponse à donner,
le premier, c'est effectivement
ce qu'on vient de dire,
c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'il y a une expérience,
et que cette expérience a l'air
d'être de bonne qualité,
tout physicien a un certain respect,
c'est-à-dire, même si la discussion
est sulfureuse,
"est-ce que ça a un intérêt ou pas? ",
oui,
mais il y a quand même une belle expérience,
donc déjà les gens acceptent de regarder,
alors que si c'est juste une discussion,
il y en a qui disent:
"J'ai pas de temps à perdre",
ça c'est le premier point.
Le deuxième point, il ne faut pas exagérer,
il n'y a pas que moi,
les expériences de Clauser étaient quand même
des expériences bien faites,
et puis il y a le fait, ça s'entend peut-être,
que j'adore expliquer,
et je dois dire que dès le début,
j'ai trouvé, me semble-t-il,
une façon d'expliquer qui était facilement
accessible à des physiciens normaux,
c'est-à-dire des physiciens qui ne
connaissaient pas particulièrement ce sujet,
mais qui avaient une culture suffisamment
large en physique
pour pouvoir suivre mes explications,
en d'autres termes, je me suis positionné
entre la vulgarisation,
je faisais aussi de la vulgarisation
mais ce n'était pas mon sujet,
je parlais à des physiciens professionnels,
mais je ne parlais pas comme le tout petit
groupe de gens que j'avais un peu fréquenté,
qui passaient leur temps à discuter entre
théorie à variables cachées du premier type,
du deuxième type, du 3ème type,
qui quelquefois à la limite, ça faisait un petit
peu discussion sur le sexe des anges,
des choses comme ça,
et ça j'étais sûr que si j'entrais
dans cette discussion là,
les physiciens "normaux"
ne m'écouteraient pas,
je pense que j'ai d'emblée trouvé
le bon positionnement qui fait que,
au bout de 10 minutes,
le physicien normal me disait:
"Ah bon c'est ça les inégalités de Bell?
Ben oui c'est ça.
Mais c'est vraiment intéressant.
C'est pour ça que je travaille dessus,
c'est parce que je trouve intéressant."
Et donc je pense que l'expérience m'a permis
d'accrocher mon auditoire,
mais je pense que j'ai aussi assez rapidement
trouvé une façon de convaincre l'auditoire
que le sujet méritait d'y passer
une demi-heure ou une heure à réfléchir.
– Alors on l'a dit tout à l'heure,
les expériences de violation
des inégalités de Bell,
il y a toujours cette question de rejeter
certaines échappatoires
comme la question de la variation
de l'orientation des polariseurs,
et donc dans les années
qui ont suivi vos expériences,
on a vu un certain nombre d'expériences
qui ont essayé de fermer en quelques sortes,
certaines des portes de plus en plus subtiles,
il y a une espèce de course,
on a l'impression,
entre les expérimentateurs qui arrivent
à fermer des échappatoires,
et puis les théoriciens qui imaginent
toujours un moyen de sauver
et j'ai l'impression moi,
qu'on annonce tous les 3 ans que:
"ça y est, on a enfin fait
des expériences sans "loophole".
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire un petit peu
où est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui
sur les différentes expériences
qui ont été faites par la suite
pour fermer ces chemins pour s'échapper?
– Alors je crois que,
bien que ce soit la façon habituelle
de présenter les choses,
je pense qu'on exagère en mettant toutes
les échappatoires au même niveau,
et je ne suis pas le seul à penser ça,
il y a une publication de John Bell,
de 1982 je crois,
avant que je publie mes résultats,
où il explique très bien,
qu'il y a d'une part ce que les gens
appellent l'échappatoire de localité,
celle qui va être fermée en bougeant
les polariseurs et les autres,
et donc je reprends finalement
l'argumentation de John Bell:
tant qu'on est en train de parler
de la possibilité
qu'il y ait une interaction de nature inconnue
entre les deux polariseurs
qui va être fermée en utilisant les principes
les plus fondamentaux de la relativité,
on va bloquer cette possibilité
en utilisant les principes
les plus fondamentaux de la relativité,
là on pense qu'il y a vraiment
une vraie différence
et c'est pour ça que, dès 1974,
j'ai voulu me lancer dans cette expérience
parce que pour moi c'était ça le fait,
et puis il y a d'autres échappatoires
qui sont de nature technologique,
par exemple le fait que dans les détecteurs
dont je disposais
et dont disposaient tous les gens à mon époque,
ce qu'on appelle le rendement quantique
des détecteurs est limité,
on ne détecte que un photon sur 5
ou 2 photons sur 5,
et là, un théoricien, comment dire,
imaginatif,
mais moi j'ai tendance à parler
de conspirationniste,
mais après tout bon, imaginatif on va dire,
peut imaginer un mécanisme dans lequel
le détecteur sélectionne les photons
qui l'arrangent bien pour donner
une violation des inégalités de Bell,
mais si on pouvait détecter les autres,
alors finalement on les violerait pas,
et là Bell a quand même une phrase
qu'il faudrait retrouver dans cet article,
mais qui est quand même assez frappante,
qui dit:
"J'ai quand même du mal à imaginer que,
avec des détecteurs
dont la détectivité est inférieure à 70%,
on a la mécanique quantique,
et que au-delà de 75 %, la mécanique
quantique s'effondre lamentablement,
bon moi je suis un petit peu
de ce point de vue,
donc moi, je n'ai pas été motivé pour aller
attaquer ces échappatoires-là,
cela dit, je pense que dès l'instant
où des gens sont assez motivés pour le faire,
c'est toujours intéressant de le faire,
et chaque fois que j'ai eu
à faire des rapports
sur des propositions d'expériences
qui visaient à ça,
dès l'instant où la proposition
était intéressante sur le plan scientifique,
j'ai toujours donné un avis favorable,
et finalement, on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure,
je pense que c'était une bonne idée,
parce que pour les applications
technologiques,
le fait d'avoir des détecteurs suffisamment
bons pour fermer cette échappatoire
est en fait très intéressant
pour les applications technologiques,
donc je pense que de toute façon que le fait
qu'on pouvait fermer les autres échappatoire,
présentait toujours un intérêt,
mais je pense, évidemment
je plaide pour ma paroisse,
mais je pense qu'à partir du moment
où on avait fermé l'échappatoire de localité,
celle qui met en jeu la relativité,
on avait fait l'essentiel du travail.
– Bon alors justement, ça me fait
une très bonne transition
parce que ma question suivante était
sur les conséquences de ces travaux-là,
on entend souvent des gens qui,
dans le débat public,
critiquent la recherche fondamentale
en disant:
"Il faut qu'il y ait des applications
économiques, technologiques,
s'il n'y a pas d'applications en vue,
ça ne sert à rien",
et ce qui est assez étonnant c'est que,
à l'époque où vous vous intéressez
à ces questions d'intrications,
de violation des inégalités de Bell,
c'est clairement une question
archi fondamentale
c'est presque philosophique voir métaphysique.
– Épistémologique.
– Voilà,
et pourtant, aujourd'hui il y a
des applications technologiques.
– Oui, alors premièrement sur la première
partie de votre question,
je m'inscris en faux,
parce que le développement
du transistor, du laser,
qui sont à la base de la société
d'information, de la communication,
c'est d'abord et en premier,
des physiciens
qui essayaient d'utiliser, de comprendre
comment le courant électrique
passe à travers certains matériaux,
en utilisant la physique quantique etc.,
donc le fait que la recherche fondamentale
doit se préoccuper d'application: non,
la recherche fondamentale progresse,
et un moment donné,
on s'aperçoit que ça sert à des applications,
toute l'histoire de la science, en tous cas
depuis le 19e siècle, peut-être même avant,
nous prouve que c'est comme ça
que ça fonctionne,
donc je refuse totalement l'argument,
mais cela dit, il est vrai que,
à ma grande surprise,
eh bien à partir de la fin des années 1980,
à un moment où j'avais complètement
abandonné ce sujet,
je m'occupais de refroidissement
d'atomes par laser etc.,
j'ai un jours rencontré un jeune physicien,
Arthur Ekert,
alors il était très poli,
il était jeune, il me dit:
"Est-ce que vous savez professeur Aspect,
avec vos photons intriqués on peut faire
de la cryptographie quantique",
alors j'ouvre des yeux grands
comme ça et je dis:
"Qu'est-ce que c'est la
cryptographie quantique
et ça peut servir à quelque chose
les photons intriqués?
il me dit: "oui oui",
et il m'a expliqué son schéma
qui est une très belle publication
dans laquelle effectivement,
en utilisant les propriétés
des photons intriqués,
et bien on peut arriver à garantir
une sécurité absolue
dans la communication entre deux partenaires,
qu'on appelle traditionnellement
Alice et Bob,
et leurs communications ne pourront
pas être interceptées
sans laisser de trace par un affreux espion.
– Alors justement, quand on regarde
le fait que, à l'époque,
l'expérience que vous proposiez n'avait pas
d'application qu'on pouvait imaginer,
j'imagine que c'était une expérience
qui nécessitait un matériel important,
qu'il a fallu des années pour faire marcher
la source de photons comme il fallait etc,
moi ça m'a donné le sentiment que,
une expérience de ce genre-là aujourd'hui
ne serait presque plus possible
avec la manière dont fonctionne la recherche,
le fait que le recrutement des jeunes
chercheurs ne se passe plus de la même façon,
une forme de précarisation,
de publisher perish.
Est-ce que vous auriez l'impression
que aujourd'hui,
vous pourriez refaire cette expérience?
– Alors, je crois qu'il faut nuancer,
c'est un peu vrai ce que vous dite,
mais après tout, il existe quand même
des chercheurs qui ont des statuts permanents,
soit au CNRS, soit de maître de conférences
à l'université,
ces chercheurs qui ont un statut permanent,
personne ne les empêche de se lancer
dans un projet à long terme,
je précise un projet à long terme
qui n'intéresse personne d'autre qu'eux,
parce que moi, c'est ça qui est extraordinaire,
pendant les 15 ans que j'ai passé
à faire ce travail, oui 10 ans on va dire,
personne n'est venu en concurrence avec moi,
parce que les gens n'avaient pas identifié
que le sujet était intéressant,
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui a un poste au CNRS,
s'il décide de faire ça,
bien sûr il va falloir qu'il convainque
les commissions du CNRS
qui évaluent régulièrement son travail,
mais tous les 2 ans ou tous les 4 ans,
il va expliquer:
"Voilà mon projet, voilà ce que j'ai fait,
voilà où j'en suis" etc.,
j'ai appartenu au comité national du CNRS,
si quelqu'un arrivait avec
un beau projet comme ça en disant:
"Je n'ai pas publié ou j'ai publié très peu
pendant les 4 années qui précèdent",
on est quand même parfaitement capable
de le comprendre
on ne met pas quelqu'un en dehors
du CNRS parce qu'il n'a pas publié,
s'il a un beau projet qui est en train
d'être développé,
donc je crois qu'il ne faut pas exagérer,
alors là je parle de la France,
il me semble qu'un maître de conférence
en France c'est la même chose,
bien sûr il a son enseignement,
mais il peut consacrer du temps à un projet
qui ne donne pas régulièrement des résultats,
alors quand même, je veux pas trop rosir
la situation,
il est vrai que la plupart des gens
ont besoin de publier
pour progresser dans leur carrière etc.
mais si on accepte que la carrière
se déroule lentement,
il me semble que c'est possible,
alors, parlons des pays étrangers,
il est vrai que dans les pays étrangers
c'est beaucoup plus difficile,
encore que, encore une fois, regardons
les États-Unis qui est un exemple,
on aime toujours citer les États-Unis,
il est vrai que tant qu'on a pas
un poste stable,
alors là il faut publier etc.,
mais du jour où on a un poste stable,
ce qui va se passer vers l'âge de 30 ans,
on peut faire ce choix aussi,
dès l'instant où on va l'expliquer
à son doyen, aux autorités,
donc je crois que ce n'est pas
un schéma habituel,
mais dire que c'est impossible,
je ne le crois pas.
– Alors bon de votre côté, Alain Aspect,
on vous invite toujours à parler
de ces fameuses expériences,
évidemment je ne déroge pas à la règle,
mais ça n'a été évidemment que le début
de votre carrière académique,
et ensuite, vous l'avez dit,
vous avez travaillé plutôt sur des sujets
différents avec de nombreux collaborateurs,
alors toujours en optique quantique,
mais dans d'autres domaines que la violation
des inégalités de Bell,
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire un mot sur
ce qu'ont été vos thèmes des recherche ensuite.
– L'autre thème de recherche,
c'est les atomes ultra-froids
donc ça s'est passé de la façon suivante,
lorsque j'ai soutenu ma thèse en 1983,
Claude Cohen-Tannoudji,
qui était déjà la référence française
et mondiale en physique quantique,
avait accepté de regarder un petit peu
ce que je faisais,
et du coup, faisait partie de tous ces gens
qui avaient constaté que ce n'était pas juste
un sujet fumeux,
mais que c'était un sujet intéressant,
donc ayant accepté de le regarder,
il avait été convaincu,
donc il faisait partie de mon sujet de thèse,
en plus il aimait bien les belles expériences,
donc il avait constaté que c'était
une belle expérience,
et lorsque en 1985, il a pensé se lancer
dans un domaine balbutiant
qui était celui du refroidissement
d'atomes par laser,
il voulait lancer un groupe,
il m'a invité tout naturellement à venir
le rejoindre pour démarrer ce groupe,
avec Jean Dalibard qui avait été stagiaire
chez moi quelques années auparavant,
il a pu m'offrir un poste de ce qu'on appelle
sous-directeur de laboratoire
au Collège de France,
qui a permis de s'embarquer
dans cette aventure,
et entre 1985 et 1992, avec Jean Dalibard
et Christophe Salomon,
nous avons été les trois mousquetaires
de Claude Cohen-Tannoudji
pour développer des expériences
qui l'ont conduit au Nobel et à Stockholm
et puis en 1992 et bien j'ai décidé d'utiliser
ces méthodes que nous avions développées
pour revenir à mes premières amours
qui est l'optique
et le contrôle des atomes
était devenu tellement fin
grâce à ses méthodes de refroidissement
d'atomes par laser,
qu'on pouvait imaginer refaire
les grandes expériences,
les expériences marquantes
d'optique quantique,
les refaire en utilisant non plus des photons,
mais des atomes,
et donc on a créé à l'Institut d'optique
en 1992-93,
un nouveau groupe de recherche
qui s'appelait: "Optique atomique",
où l'objet était de revisiter
les grandes étapes de l'optique
avec les photons remplacés par les atomes,
puisque nous avions appris à
très bien maîtriser les atomes,
et aujourd'hui je suis à la retraite,
mais je suis quand même émérite,
et ce groupe existe toujours,
et nous avons effectivement revisité
un certain nombre de grandes expériences
de l'optique quantique,
et il en reste encore une qui est en cours,
toujours en cours, c'est de revisiter:
les inégalités de Bell.
– D'accord, très bien, merci beaucoup
Alain Aspect de m'avoir reçu,
d'avoir répondu à mes questions.
– Ça a été un plaisir, et je tiens à dire
que j'apprécie beaucoup toutes
les vidéos que vous faites,
je trouve ça un magnifique
travail d'explication
dont j'espère qu'il en sera de même
pour ces inégalités de Bell.
– Merci
– Écoute, c'est tout pour moi est-ce que…
– Ça baigne?
– 47 minutes, on est bien
– (Voix hors champs) Juste en technique,
quand Jupiter est intervenu,
extrêmement péremptoire,
je ne sais pas ce que vous comptez
en faire de cette partie-là.
– Je verrai, je crois que c'était
au moment où tu disais:
"Trancher entre Bohr et Einstein"
– Trancher un débat entre Bohr et Einstein.
– Pas mal.
[Coup de tonnerre à l'extérieur]
– Pas mal, qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de ça?
[– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -]